نبدا نشره بهذه الصور المباشره من تل ابيب
حيث خرج الالاف في احتجاجات جديده بتل
ابيب ضد خطط رئيس الوزراء بن امينه الياهو
لتغيير النظام القضائي مطالبين بالغاء
وليس فقط تاجيل كما فعل نتنياهو استجابه
لتلك الضغوط طبعا بيان الحركه الاحتجاجيه
قال بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه فشلت في كل
المجالات وتعتزم تمرير معتبروه انقلاب
قضائيا خلال عطله الكنيسه عطله الكنيسه
بدلا من التركيز على الامن خاصه في ظل
الاحداث الاخيره
والتصعيد ما بين جنوب لبنان
وقطاع غزه بعد الاحداث الاخيره في المسجد
الاقصى
ايضا نقل حي ومباشر لهذه التظاهرات التي
لم تنتهي ولم تتوقف منذ اسابيع طويله
احتجاجا على تعديلات التي كان رئيس
الوزراء
يريد ادخالها على نظام القضائي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات